LARRY ARNN: Vital
causes are the things
that we seek above all others.
The things we would die for.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you read the Declaration
of Independence,
you will find that it
comes in three parts,
and in the first part it states
some universal principles.
Very beautiful.
And in the second part,
it contains a bill
of particulars in 17
paragraphs about bad stuff
the King of England did,
which bad stuff justifies
the making of America,
throwing off the old government
and adopting a new one.
And those things are remarkably
like the Constitution United
States.
What did the King do wrong?
Well, he interfered
with the legislature,
which is a violation of the
first step in all government,
the making of laws, but also
a violation of separation
of powers, which
is crucial to how
the Constitution of the
United States worked.
So separation of
powers is important,
and then he interfered
with the people's ability
to elect legislators, in
other words, representation,
a key feature of the
Constitution of the United
States.
And then he interfered
with the judges.
He would ship people.
Arrest them for crimes and
ship them off to England
where they couldn't be tried
by a jury of their peers
nor before judges
who are independent
of the executive branch, which
more or less the King was.
So you see, they're writing
the Constitution right there.
If you have a government
that does these things,
then you are justified to
rebel against that government
and to kill anybody
who resists you.
So it implies the Constitution.
Now, they are different the
Declaration of Independence
and the Constitution, they
serve different functions.
They also sound different
in a very interesting way.
The Declaration of Independence
is really beautiful.
"When in the course
of human events,
it becomes necessary
for one people
to dissolve the political
bands that have connected them
with another, and to assume
among the powers of the Earth
the separate and equal station
to which the laws of nature
and nature's God entitle them."
Isn't that a grand
expression the laws
of nature and of nature's God?
It's written like that.
Also, it's not time bound.
When in the course
of human events,
that means anytime in the
course of human events,
it becomes necessary for
one people, that means
any people, anywhere, any time.
The claim is what's going to
follow in this document is
right at all times.
And so one way to think
about the difference
between the Declaration
of the Constitution
is it's a document about
ultimate purposes, what
they call in classic
philosophy final causes.
Final causes are the things
that we seek above all others.
The things we would die for.
Well, the Constitution
is not quite like that.
The Constitution-- it
provides a form of government.
And when you read it, I've
regarded it as beautiful
and think I understand
why it's beautiful.
It has to do with
its structure which
Madison says is the most
important thing about it.
But on any given passage,
it's full of details.
There's a list in
Article I, Section
8, things the Congress can do.
Well, post offices and
post roads is among them.
It's hard to write a
beautiful sentence about that.
No, this is a document about how
the government's going to work,
even how it's going to look.
It looks like a thing that
operates in three branches.
If there's interviews going on
in front of the White House,
which there are every
day on the nightly news,
there's a picture of the
White House in the background
because that's where
the president works
and that's where
executive things are done.
And if there's something
big in the Congress,
then there's cameras looking
up at the Capitol dome
because that's where
the Congress operates
and where the legislation is and
the same for the Supreme Court
building.
In operation, the government
looks like the Constitution,
and so it's become
a very great country
in the course of its history.
Beyond the imaginings
even of the people
who founded it who were
extremely ambitious people.
They had the highest
possible hopes.
Well, if that's true, there
must have been some cause of it,
but also it's in
that final purpose
we serve that we have
adopted its purpose
available to all human beings.
We have adopted it for our own.
SPEAKER: Thank you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our highlight series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.